see what other things that really struck
me is that you centers really look to
add so much value and like I'm a
business school student that's kind of
one of those oh we add value but I saw
it certain themes and everything that
you talked about which is like
communicating communicate it was like
communicating your wife with your people
and then the other part of that was like
really to get in the trenches with those
it was like by our system you're on a
message board and respond in town today
it's not glamorous just to throw at your
wife's calendar to kind of communicate
and really it's just being a
practitioner right like nobody talks
about that part like everybody just
think you're gonna build it [ __ ] it's
gonna happen like a cattle stampede you
know wrap something Goods gonna have
Nationals gonna mention that [ __ ]
doesn't work and so if you're playing
marathon you need to be prepared for a
marathon and that puts it into work you
know and everybody's training for a
sprint in our space the amount of people
have literally reverse-engineer we're
going to do this in Flint and that is it
the perfect blueprint to be out of
business pretty quickly especially do
you guys think the most vulnerable is
your to time now where you're about to
start now we've had a nice little bubble
room here right you should see what
happens in three years or four years
legit it's the fan right and then nobody
for anybody and that one right so we're
looking at a complete false reality and
start a plan for the last five years and
that's dangerous for a lot of people
that want to be successful you have you
the kid in Business School a good kid a
good hustle there is your version he's
running around the world right now let
him tell you the story about what he was
doing
Business School how he had 84 trillion
dollars on paper and valium and then
April came and it was all gone and then
he worked at IBM or Fox right I know
seven billion people like that and right
now there's complete lack of awareness
from us that that is our narrative then
we're going to do this we're not going
to happen the economic thing will happen
like it always does we wait to live job
or you do that not glamorous stuff you
actually build a [ __ ] business
instead of a toy right and you have
enough money to sustain that and then
actually really killing because you went
through the back part got a later grab
you know the companies like Amazon and
eBay that like one in two thousand two
thousand wanted to write that what
sounds more interesting to me